i'll tell you what these like wikipedias
sometimes are crazy
sometimes they do know a lot but like
sometimes they are so off base that i'm
like
what and why hey gq
i'm zendaya and i'm going undercover on
the internet
this is actually me
okay uh let's check twitter
who is your favorite harry potter
character at hogwarts house
people may say this is basic but i'm
gonna go with harry potter himself
and gryffindor why because when i went
to the harry potter museum for my
birthday
they told me that when they asked people
who their favorite character is
people never say harry somehow because
he's the lead character and he
is like the chosen one people decide not
to choose him because they think they're
being cool
but he is the chosen one people all
right and he's been through a lot
since he's a g so i'm going with harry i
feel like i'm a gryffindor because
out boys love lions so i just feel like
that just it just feels right
and harry's
alright now let's check out some youtube
comments
two months ago how the emmy got there
that fast
fun fact everyone who participated in
emmys
there was somebody standing outside of
everyone's
home i believe with a hazmat suit and an
emmy and
if you win you got to keep the enemy and
if you did not
they took it so there was a lovely young
woman
outside of my house with a hazmat suit
and darnell
who is my like my brother and my
assistant when he heard the news he
grabbed it and ran in with it so that's
how i got there so fast
replied can you believe that there are
kids out there who only know zendaya
from spider-man and the greatest showman
and not from shake it up at her disney
days i feel so old
there was also someone today through
their car
or through my car that saw me that said
she was like holding her phone and she
was like
through her mask you know saying like i
used to love shake it up
and this is like i have a video on my
phone of like me dancing to it i think
for her like
elementary school something i don't know
and it was just so cute
because obviously she's grown now and
it's just cool
to see the fact that people have grown
with me and taken this journey with me
so
yeah i appreciate anyone who has seen
anything that i do
or cares at all but yeah i love seeing
the people that have grown up with me
because we're all kind of done this
thing together okay
next uh zindaya hi what do you remember
from casey undercover and who are you
still friends with from that show
i remember a lot and it wasn't that long
ago that's the kind of funny thing is it
feels like a long time ago it was like a
different phase of my career but it was
actually
the last thing i did before i went and
did euphoria so
i remember everything and yes i am so
close with mostly everyone from that
show
they really were my family kadeem
partisan is one of the closest people to
me is like a mentor
a brother camille is like my brother for
those of you who probably know i hang
out with him all the time
he plays video games with me he's taught
me to play video games in my adult life
veronica everyone everyone i'm very
lucky
one question on a scale of 1 to 10 how
much do you still love
cup of noodles here's the thing
i'm a vegetarian and it always says it's
chicken flavor
and i always thought it was like well
that's just like a flavoring it's not
like real chicken in there
but i saw something that said it was
like essentially chicken powder and so i
was like well
i can't eat this because it has chicken
in it and i felt like a fraud because
i've been essentially eating chicken
powder so
i cannot eat it anymore so i've since
gotten rid of
cup of noodles and topped ramen all
together
which is yeah i feel horrible that i
didn't know that i don't know i guess i
just thought it was like artificial
flavoring but i guess
there is real chicken
in it i've never said that out loud
sucks
okay cora
how doesn't they dress so well all the
time i have a secret weapon his name is
la
roach he is my stylist since i was
literally 14 years old i've never been
with anyone else
he is my fashion soul mate he's taught
me a lot
about not just fashion but
self-confidence
and i think self-expression through
clothing and i'm not always
fashionable you know like i got a cool
shirt but like i will admit
under here are some nice basketball
shorts posted
zendaya i really don't work out me how
i don't know man i don't enjoy working
out i really wish i did because i feel
like it would be good for me
and i tried in quarantine i did like
maybe five days consistently i was like
you know what this is gonna be my thing
like i gotta keep my body active but i
gotta do this
uh it didn't last very long and the way
that i got myself to keep going every
day
to work out was like i would put on
different wigs
and pretend to be different characters
because i just was craving acting i
guess and i would just like do these
funny skits for darnell because it was
just me and him in the house and
every day i'd surprise him with a new
character and i walked downstairs ready
to go work out
again that only lasted about five days
so
seriously it's actually me oh this is
actually to me and arnold do you have
any tips on dealing with stress and
anxiety
i mean if you got some ideas let us just
enough i'm kind of trying to navigate
that myself
stress and anxiety is a constant factor
in my life due to
my work and how tough i am with myself
and so
i'm kind of on my own discovery of what
are the best ways to kind of manage that
in a healthy way trying to do things
that bring me joy whether that be the
painting
or writing sometimes you kind of have to
force yourself to do it but it is really
really helpful i found just like writing
things out and getting out your thoughts
on paper and working through it in that
way
and also just having someone that you
can call and just vent to that is just
allows you the space hold space for you
and you hold space for them
i think that's really helpful but also
another thing i've found also just being
outside
in nature obviously safely so i go on
hikes that
nobody is ever around me it's just me
and like darnell and my dog and just
kind of
getting to get some fresh air and being
amongst
you know treason
do you really bite your ice cream if so
that's not right
yes i do i don't really have the same
kind of sensitivity in my teeth
that people normally have with cold
foods i know
normally for people that would be a
horrible
sensation but for me i don't really feel
much so it doesn't bother me
today can you please recommend your
favorite books by shakespeare i really
want to try reading one but i don't
really know where to start
and you seem like an expert well i
haven't read shakespeare in a really
long time mostly because i grew up on it
and
it just was so much a part of i think my
childhood because my mother worked at
the california shakespeare theater ever
since i was about
two years old so i just lived around it
i didn't even know
the kind of the special experience that
i really got because it felt so normal
to me it was really
cool for me and for me i like the more
romantic ones
you know the as you like it's the
midsummer night streams those ones
are my favorites but then i also really
like the intense ones
as well whether it be like richard iii
or othello
and so on and so forth it just depends
on what the mood you're into and if
you're not used to shakespeare it can be
confusing and there
are books like no fear shakespeare and
things like that that can like help you
translate the text and make it a little
bit easier for you to understand if you
get stuck
oh so happy that a black artist won this
well i appreciate that
gene i appreciate it it was quite a
special moment for
myself and hopefully for a lot of other
people i feel very honored
let's see what instagram wants to know
you feel perfect when you're with noon
don't you
i'll tell you what dogs the best noon
is absolutely my emotional support dog i
take i
well at least i try to take him
everywhere he usually comes to work with
me
he's like very well behaved said dog and
it is nice to just like go in your
trailer
after working long days and just having
a little puppy there
that just loves you and wants to see you
every time and that just feels good
unless my mom is there
then he could care less that i'm there
let's see what is on
wikipedia
zenay was born since september 1st 1996
true
in oakland california true the child of
claire marie stormer and kazimbe
quarterly from true she has five older
half siblings on her father's side
her father is african-american with
roots in arkansas while her mother has
german and scottish ancestry
that's all true that's all good this
must be updated because i'm telling you
the last song was on there they were
like yeah her mom's from like
norway or something i don't know and i
was like what no
this is actually accurate so well done
to whoever you know
typed this information or found it out
how do you know this
what was the day pullman like in high
school well
i didn't go to regular high school so i
did high school on a set in a room with
the teacher
and myself so my high school experience
wasn't necessarily typical
i was working a lot i was mostly by
myself so i didn't really have any like
other students to kind of navigate
you know my normal high school
experience with so it's a little bit
different
mdp
[Music]
was not told what film she was
auditioning for when she tested for a
role in spider-man homecoming until
after she got accepted
so during the audition she presumed it
was just some random high school comedy
thing
kinda sorta we weren't supposed to know
that the script pages that we were
reading were for spider-man
but i did find out that it was for
spider-man because i have good agents
but i didn't know what role i was
auditioning for
i just thought it was girl in spider-man
movie i didn't really know
what character or what kind of
character they would be right before the
screen test they were kind of saying
okay these are the characters that we're
reading for
mj being one of them and i was like
submit girl i need to know your skincare
routine
i think the best thing for me that i've
found is just consistency is key
sticking with products and keeping it
simple i have very sensitive skin and i
can't do much
so i have to do like fragranceless kind
of situations and just keep it really
really
simple like cleanser moisturizer don't
do too much because
when i start to apply too many layers of
things and too many different masks and
too many different things
i break out or i get an eczema flare up
so i gotta
keep it simple that's really all i got
for you and wear your sunscreen
alright gq that is it i am signing off